lavrov le dit la guerre nucléaire et
dans la tête des européens pas des
russes et puis il ya une phrase qui a
retenu notre attention armelle
l'occident nous écoute mais ne nous
entend pas ça veut dire beaucoup ça veut
dire beaucoup parce que c'était
important que la position russe
s'exprime on est dans un conflit et
quand on veut à un moment donné que les
choses se tassent il faut effectivement
que les uns et les autres prennent le
temps d'écouter
sergueï lavrov l'avantagent qu'il a
c'est qu'il est au pouvoir chez viennent
regarder depuis 18 ans précisément en
fonction en fonction voilà mais du coup
ça l'amène avoir une compréhension des
éléments ça l'amène à savoir parler à
savoir structure et du coup sa démarche
et lorsqu'il explique effectivement que
l'occident ne comprends pas il refuse en
fait qu'il y ait une guerre entre
poutine et l'ukraine en quelque sorte et
il mais cela au delà et c'est justement
ça ce que le président français tout
leur disais non l inverse on est
effectivement
directement avec poutine c'est cette
position qui est de dire finalement
aujourd'hui nous sommes isolés et on est
isolé parce qu'on toutes les lignes
rouges que l'on a posé on n'a pas été
entendu on n'a pas été entendue sur la
question de l'ukraine comme étant en
fait un endroit dans lequel on ne
voulait pas qu'il y ait une menace
occidental qu'ils puissent se mettre en
place ce fameux élargissement et de
l'otan vers l'est notamment vers la
pologne et la roumanie qui a posé tant
de problèmes ces dernières années
l'ukraine c'était vraiment peut-être la
dernière ligne rouge pour vladimir
poutine c'est tout à fait sa dernière
ligne rouge en reprenant effectivement
un peu d'histoire c'est à dire qu'au
départ quand cette alliance n'est c'est
effectivement pour avoir ce rempart avec
la russie qui vient en fait de
s'affaiblir si on est à la sortie de
donc qu'au moment où le mur tombe et on
à cette heure-ci qui est un peu faible
et il ya cette fameuse promesse de ne
pas s'élargit mal les termes aujourd'hui
sont discutées finalement que ce qu'ont
dit les occidentaux à ce moment là la
russie
s'il n'y a pas de texte véritablement
écrit sur quoi on se base en fait on se
base sur le fait que quand les russes
disent on veut avoir une sécurité on
veut avoir une profondeur stratégique on
veut donc du coup avoir des pays qui ne
nous sont pas hostiles à côté et ce qui
est intéressant c'est par exemple la
terminologie sur le nucléaire c'est vrai
que les russes ont réécrit en fait il ya
fait allusion à un moment donné la
doctrine sur le nucléaire en 2020 jules
contexte j'ai plus tendre le relire et
on voit que les choses sont posés noir
sur blanc et donc ils écrivent
effectivement qu'à partir du moment
donné ou des pays arrivent sur leur
frontière et que même s'ils sont en
armes conventionnelles mais leur sont
hostiles et leur sont plus nombreux dans
ces cas-là lusage et la réflexion de
l'arme nucléaire elle est envisageable
donc ce sont des choses qui sont montés
et sur lequel ils ont écrit des choses
c'était en 2020 nous sommes maintenant
en 2022 pareil la précision russe sur la
notion effectivement de l'utilisation de
l'armé nucléaire qui est de rappeler que
l'otan n'est pas une alliance
stratégique c'est exact souvent on
entend l'otan est une alliance
stratégique mais le nucléaire reste à la
main des états souverains c'est pour ça
que en fait il l'a dit ce sont les
américains qui ont l'armé nucléaire dont
c'est eux qui peuvent l'utiliser il ya
deux pays qui auront l'armé nucléaire
c'est le royaume uni qui en l'occurrence
aujourd'hui peut effectivement s'en
servir mais ne peut pas le faire
techniquement s'il n'a pas la corde et
américains il ya un pays qui fait ce
qu'il veut c'est la france nous sommes
souverains alors pourquoi est ce qu'on
dit que on a le nucléaire n'est pas dans
la dans le la dans l'otan tout
simplement parce que dans ces cas là on
n'a pas le déclaré aujourd'hui le
président français élu quel qu'il soit
il n'a pas de compte à rendre à qui que
ce soit sur le nombre de missiles que
l'on a ou est-ce qu'on as où sont nos
sous marins nucléaires puisque nous nous
sommes en alerte permanente prêt à tirer
où sont nos rafale ou nos mirage 2000 on
n'a strictement rien à dire donc c'est
là dessus en fait qu'on revient sur
cette menace et sa montre en fait la
problématique russe aujourd'hui qui est
de dire nous voulons avoir du bilatéral
les uns avec les autres mais ne
positionner pas l'otan trop près et ne
positionner pas un autant nucléarisé
face à nos portes et on va justement
écoutez un extrait de cette intervention
de sergueï lavrov le ministre rue des
affaires étrangères qui nous parle
justement de ces menaces ou en tout cas
de cette menace de l'otan en ukraine
potentiellement écouté il maniait
mongeau baulche poison nous ne pouvons
pas admettre les menaces venues
d'ukraine ou contre la russie l'ukraine
veut à tout prix intégrer l'otan et
l'otan ne tient pas sa promesse de ne
pas s'élargir davantage
ils renforcent leur propre sécurité au
détriment de celle des autres ribaut
auto que le plectre hoyaux 2 ap à 16 h
ou
alors il ya évidemment beaucoup de
choses à retenir armelle sur sept heures
d'intervention notamment sur les
accusations de génocide d'horus dans le
donbass sergueï lavrov le dit nos
partenaires européens ne nous entendent
pas il cite notamment la france et
l'allemagne alors il ya eu 14 mille
personnes tuées aujourd'hui dans le
donbass entre 2014 et maintenant c'est
soyons clairs une guerre oubliée c'est
une guerre sur lequel tout le monde a
fermé les yeux parce que ça arrangeait
tout le monde ça me comble un conflit
larvé c'est un confit là où il y avait
peut-être quelques morts chaque semaine
mais sa durée comme ça pendant huit ans
malheureusement en diplomatie il faut
aussi avoir quelques lâcheté parfois ça
permet d'éviter d'arriver directement à
l'affrontement donc sur ce sens ces
questions là
véritablement nous les européens on peut
fermer les yeux on a fermé les yeux bien
sûr sur ce qui se passe et s'arranger
les russes parce que du coup ils n'ont
pas non plus donné particulièrement
besoin qu'il y avait des accords de
minsk et qui devait faire en sorte que
du coup le président ukrainien devait
discuter avec les séparatistes
les russes avaient choisi d'être dans
une position il a veillé nous ont fait
pas partie du conflit on n'est pas dans
ces accords là tout ce qui était quand
même un peu fou parce qu'ils étaient
quand même rentrer aussi mais l'un dans
l'autre tout cela tenait tenait mal mais
tenez or aujourd'hui il ya eu des
massacres effectivement mais est-ce
qu'on peut pas utiliser le terme de
génocide
il est certainement trop fort ils ce
sont des enquêtes en clair qui
permettent d'avoir ça mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est d'entendre
effectivement que healy à cette position
russe qui est de regarder ce qui se
passe sur des personnes qu'ils
considèrent être un peu comme eux et
donc aussi y avait une allusion sur le
fait que la langue russe ne soient plus
utilisés
qui pour eux est effrayant en disant
mais on doit utiliser toutes les langues
alors c'est certainement pas ça qui a
amené à une invasion effectivement de
l'ukraine mais on entend effectivement
du coup la difficulté avec ça l'autre
problème majeur que souligner les russes
c'est toute cette classification de
l'ukraine qu'on dit des d'asie fier et
qui est largement repris par lavrov
alors qu on pourrait s'imaginer qu'à un
moment donné ça soit aussi un peu
abandonnés parce qu'il dit là vous nous
n'écoutez pas et vous ne vous rendez pas
compte de ce qui est en train de se
passer là encore un petit peu d'histoire
là quand il ya une guerre aujourd'hui
qui se met en place le risque qu'il y
ait en place des milices pro d'asie en
ukraine existent elles ont eu lieu
effectivement la vue en 2014 et lé
ministre d'azov qui effectivement
arborer une croix gammée et qui du coup
intervenait le risque est extrêmement
aujourd'hui parce que vous pouvez avoir
des milices qui se re surgissent et qui
du coup apple j'allais dire tous les néo
nazis d'europe ou du monde à venir
combattre sur place et en fait ce risque
là simplement ce qu'on peut répondre
c'est qu'il est aussi portée par les
russes qui lors ce qu'ils appellent des
troupes tchétchènes les troubles du
daguestan où lorsqu'on pense qu'il peut
y avoir wagner qui vient d'intervenir ça
fait partie effectivement des
mercenariat requis non sans foi ni loi
et qui arrange bien les états mais il
dit que cette question-là fait que du
queen's ne se ressent pas assez écoutée
par les dirigeants que ce soit le
chancelier allemand où que ce soit le
président macron dont il attend quelque
chose mais s'il a signé effectivement
s'il a signalé que nicolas sarkozy avait
obtenu quelque chose en georgie il a
laissé la porte ouverte cela au
président macron sachant que comme c'est
un président en campagne il ne veut pas
trop faire de cadeaux dans qu aux
français et il lui a un peu taper dessus
lors lorsqu'il a dit que emmanuel macron
disait que le nazisme s'épanouit en
ukraine que ceci est un mensonge il l'a
répété à deux reprises que le président
français bien se tromper sur ce point-là
précis et il faut peut-être ajouter
aussi parce que on comprend peut-être
mieux la position russe que le président
macron était en fait ministre des
finances sous françois hollande au
moment où la france
a barré le contrat consignes avec eux ou
à leur vendait le bepc le porte
hélicoptères et que donc du coup ça et
des biens les russes la france a pris
une vraie décision à ce moment là en
disant nous nous respecterons des
engagements puisque nous avons pris
position par rapport la guerre en
ukraine est-ce que effectivement les
russes qui ont la mémoire longue font
payer au président français élu ce qu'il
a effectivement vu passer sous son nez à
ce moment là ça fait partie des
possibilités
merci